un último esfuerzo para invalidar los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu
texas estado bajo control republicano se
unió a esta causa presentar una demanda
en la corte suprema el fiscal general
del estado y quien está bajo una
investigación federal por corrupción
denunció a los estados pendulares de
georgia michigan pensilvania y wisconsin
por presuntas irregularidades en las
elecciones la demanda repite una serie
de acusaciones falsas sin pruebas y sin
soporte de una votación ilegal y también
de papeletas irregulares enviadas por
correo en estos cuatro estados el martes
de presidente de montreux aplaudió en
twitter esta decisión con una mención al
coraje y la brillantez de texas sin
embargo de acuerdo con algunos expertos
la demanda tiene pocas opciones para
salir adelante especialmente después de
que el martes terminara el plazo para
que todos los estados se edificarán sus
resultados electorales el profesor de
derecho de la universidad de california
rich eisen escribió en su blog que este
es un comunicado de prensa disfrazado
como una demanda
texas no tiene el estatus para realizar
estas denuncias ya que no tiene voz
sobre como otros estados eligen a sus
electores
el profesor de derecho de la universidad
de texas steve blake tuiteó que parece
que tenemos un nuevo líder en la
categoría de demanda más loca presentada
para supuestamente desafiar las
elecciones
trump y sus abogados han entablado
numerosas demandas en estados clave con
la esperanza de invalidar la victoria de
job aire pero con poco éxito el martes
la corte suprema dio un nuevo revés a
las ambiciones del mandatario cuando de
manera unánime rechazó otra demanda de
los republicanos que pretendía anular el
resultado que ya había sido certificado
y entregado en pensilvania aunque no hay
evidencia de fraude
trump se sigue negando a conceder la
derrota ante job airén y admitir que
perdió los comicios